[Música]
no começo meu pai fazendo uma pergunta o
que tem valor vai te alguns dias atrás o
brasil viveu um caos
quando nós caminhoneiros resolveram
parar na beira das estradas e protestar
por algo que me incomodava e disfasia
falta e desse acontecimento que marcou a
nossa história eu vou destacar três
pontos que acho importante para a gente
analisar juntos
o primeiro deles é o processo de tomada
de decisão que aconteceu de uma maneira
totalmente distribuída
os caminhoneiros espalhados pelo país
todo se comunicando de redes sociais
decidindo quando iam se movimentasse e
movimentar sim aceitar aquilo que estava
acontecendo
o papel do estado tentando fazer uma
regulação da economia em meio ao caos
instaurado tentando se comunicar com
lideranças e de alguma forma fazer o
país voltar a andar em terceiro lugar
nós como indivíduos ea maneira com que
nós nos relacionamos com os recursos
eu não sou um grande consumidor de
combustíveis não me desloco tanto pela
pela cidade
mas eu tenho uma família enorme eu tenho
três filhos moro com meu sogro e minha
sogra e esposa
não tenho pra pagar e nem gato e
cachorro mas sete pessoas é o meu grande
ea gente se preocupa que vai acontecer
com alimento vai acabar vai chegar
a gente tem que tomar alguma ação ou não
várias dúvidas várias conversas vários
aprendizados um acontecimento que para
alguns pode ser quase tão simples fato é
que nos últimos dez anos
uma tecnologia fez com que nós pararmos
para pensar sobre o processo de tomada
de decisão sobre o papel do estado na
economia e sobre a nossa relação com os
recursos essa tecnologia se chama nada
mais é do que uma tecnologia que permite
que uma pessoa em um determinado lado
transporte algo um recurso para alguém
que está do outro lado e do outro lado
do mundo os consumidores dessa
tecnologia
o grupo em comunidades como se fossem
tribos essas tribos estão distribuídas
mundo afora
cada uma delas tem as suas próprias
regras e os recursos que para elas fazem
sentido e que circulam dentro dessas
comunidades
a tribo mais famosa de todas elas é a
tribo do bitcoin certeza já ouviram
falar uma maioria de vocês é como se
fosse uma moeda digital que tem uma
característica de ser raro como ouro ou
seja ao longo do tempo ele vai ficando
escasso decorre hoje é utilizado pra
diversas operações mas ele pode ser
usado para comprar um item na internet
ele pode ser usado para comprar um
apartamento
o ele pode ser utilizado como por
exemplo aconteceu aqui no rio grande do
sul para comprar vaca e isso aconteceu
no ano passado
a agropecuarista as brasileiras entraram
em contato
um deles entusiastas de tecnologia
ofereceu dar a outro pagamento pela
compra de uma rês fazer o pagamento
usando um kit com essa transação
aconteceu aqui no rio grande do sul
existe também atribuir diferentes em
alguns aspectos
o principal deles é que os membros dessa
comunidade cada um deles pode criar sua
própria moeda pode criar o seu próprio
dinheiro virtual e essas regras de
funcionamento desse processo ficam só
no chamado contrato inteligente que nada
mais é do que com um software que contém
todas essas regras de emissão e
distribuição desse recurso que está
sendo criado nessa plataforma que leva o
nome de tolkien que é o nome popular
dentro dessa essa trio fato é que na
prática isso é mais ou menos como um
software que roda no celular ou no
computador que você utiliza interage com
ele ele distribui dados pra pessoas
mundo afora então esses arquivos que e
as transações que circulam são
armazenadas esses arquivos estão
distribuídos e acessíveis a todos ou
seja quando o recurso sai de uma pessoa
é uma pessoa de um elemento dessa tribo
é escolhido para validar se essa
transação de fato tal de acordo com as
regras e isso é feito de uma maneira
aleatória
essa pessoa escolhida ganha uma pequena
recompensa por ter feito essa validação
ea informação é distribuída para todos
que fazem parte dessa comunidade
para ilustrar um pouco melhor o
funcionamento disse eu vou contar pra
vocês
a história de seu nakamoto nakamoto ele
é um produtor de yogurte do interior do
estado e pela primeira vez teve um
cliente da capital
o senhor vital e resolveu adquirir seus
deliciosos de iogurtes porém o senhor
vital tem uma preocupação
a preocupação dele é que o jogo esteja
armazenada nas devidas condições de
temperatura durante todo o processo de
transporte
por outro lado seu nakamoto também tem a
sua preocupação ele quer ter certeza que
o cliente tem dinheiro suficiente para
poder pagar a despesa da conta dos
rebotes
ouvindo isso sato aqui do seu nakamoto
desse pai usa uma bota pra isso coloca
as regras dessa compra no contrato
inteligente e assim você isso é vital
vão poder fazer essa transação com
segurança
e isso foi feito assim seu namoro ioiô
urt topo e as regras de funcionamento
desse negócio ficaram colocadas num
contrato inteligente e basicamente faz
com que o senhor vital deposite o
dinheiro da compra uma moeda virtual
garantido
esse dinheiro mas que ele ainda não foi
repassado ao seu nakamoto e o seu
nakamoto colocou um sensor dentro do
caminhão que de tempos em tempos
atualiza o blog chin atualiza esse
contato inteligente mostrando a
temperatura do rio verde
ao final do processo todos os membros
dessa comunidade moto em que suporta
essa funcionamento tem as informações de
que tudo o que aconteceu está correto e
validado e quando a entrega for feita na
temperatura correta e com o pagamento
feito de forma adequada
basta 22 do ok nesse processo e que a
transação vai ser concluído contrato
encerrado
os valores vão ser transportados de
maneira automática
parece algo meio né fantástico até coisa
meio de filme mas na prática é o que
está acontecendo já nos estados unidos
um grande empresa do varejo já faz isso
com seus fornecedores fazendo um registo
totalmente transparente aberta das
transações que acontecem no bloquinho
mas uma botinha não serve somente para
esse tipo de operações
ela também serve para a criação de
moedas ela pode ser utilizada para que
uma pessoa do outro lado do mundo
consiga investir na agricultura familiar
do brasil ela pode permitir com que um
refugiado que tem que sair da sua terra
e visitar um outro país a morar num
outro país fugir para outro país consiga
levar alguma coisa de seu sustento
permite que os familiares que moram que
deixaram sua terra natal para morar em
outro país possam ajudar suas famílias
elite com que pessoas que nunca tiveram
acesso a serviços financeiros consigo
ter um pouco de dignidade e acesso a
serviços de baixo custo e com uma
facilidade enorme de trânsito de valores
e aí eu volto a falar pra vocês porque
pela primeira vez uma tecnologia nos fez
repensar o processo de tomada de decisão
o papel do estado na economia ea nossa
relação com os recursos bote nos faz
repensar o papel o processo de tomada de
decisão porque a partir do momento em
que nós temos como comunidade
regras claras sobre as nossas relações e
conseguimos fazer com que as decisões
sejam tomadas por consenso
isso torna isso muito mais rápido muito
mais fácil e muito mais transparente nos
faz repensar o papel do estado na
economia porque a partir do momento que
uma comunidade consegue materializar
aquilo que faz sentido aquilo que é o
valor para si uma moeda que circula de
maneira rápida e transparente nos fazer
pensar real necessidade de ter uma casa
da moeda
gerando dinheiro de papel ao seu bel
prazer nos faz repensar a relação com os
recursos porque a partir do momento que
eu posso criar valor e uma comunidade
pode criar valor e a circulação desse
valor nessa comunidade que dita o valor
real daquilo que está acontecendo
nós conseguimos materializar algo que de
fato faz sentido para nós então eu
finalizo dizendo para vocês que locke em
nada mais é do que uma tecnologia que
vai dizer se essa tecnologia vai fazer o
bem ou não como nós somos nós que vamos
fazer essa tecnologia gerar valores
especuladores no mercado de armas
vantagem uma pessoa de outra irá nos
bolhas econômicas mas também pode ser a
tecnologia que vai fazer com que a gente
leve dignidade da pessoa que está lá no
rincão distante no interior do brasil e
da áfrica do paquistão assim é ela que
vai nos fazer elevar o nível de
transparência nas relações como pessoas
como comunidade como assim como empresas
ela que pode nos permitir fazemos
diferente aquilo que nos incomoda
a tecnologia é uma ferramenta terminar
minha fala da mesma forma que eu comecei
em valor relativo
[Aplausos]